D
BEGINNING.BLE THECAS THAN MILE
TUMBLED ANAN OUT ASG
PL CURREYND LOSENDTHE  LOSTHAN
B
B000 FO THE SCH ALL I
TH L OR SO.ETHERESERDAY'S HIGH.S
BEMARKET'SYING,
HE CAN GET THESE PROPOSALS>> RA
AID JUSTTUHE NEARLY OFFICE.IS R.
AND HE IS GOINGALL FOR
INEALAYBUT THE QUEST IS HOW CCTE
TLAN IS NOING TO END T'S NOT
TO BNE
ARE S AGA OF THESETAS. THE AUDA
MI, MANCH
FROM WESVI TABOUT SO MUS BE ABSI
ROSE
CORPORAT TRUCTURE, T PLANSLSO B
SAMEEROSED OAP GAINS T. N
WILL GO UPECT.
THECOE
TE ALMOST CERTAINLY N UP PROPOS
BUW ICAL
DO Y EE TOPENOW, BD HH THE , A
WAS AEFTRALONG. TO S POTI THESE
TAXARD, I THI HAR ALL
HITICAL CAPITAL.TH IS BHE REAL
T
WESE TY WILL GNETO
ANT KOGETHERRAN TENATE.NKNGO
IT.TH MUCH ARE
ME T AND IT IS BACKS OF THE  MAN
FROM ARIZO,E KEY HI
K WATCH
REPRESIDENCYTIICANS HA
SO IT ISDEMOCRATS HERE A VHERE.
THE WHIT GOING TO
G O IOIT TO GET AS   JEFF, HEKE
AVENUENTALLY
OF THE G
WALL
SO, AEMILLIOLLNT INCOME PAYS AAM
2 IN TAXES O T W S.THE OWER RA-
R. BIDEIS CAR THEY COULE
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO RTHAT39%.
SEE
Y  THE SAYS IT COULD  T GTHE PRL
I CAN PAY FOR
NGE WITHL GAINS.PEOPLEUL O NAYS
COMING.
HEDA CA
THINKT' LL,HA MKETI T IS A STAS
FORWARD-LOOKT' S ATQUITHEREG  RE
FOR TAXING CAPITAL AT AHA0YEARSG
AND WOULD IT BE A BF
THAT GOES? JUST TOO
MA U HAVES,ES
ON CATANSALE
XEPOATH, UPON REAL
ALLY A GOOD
THING.
THE MOR YOU RAISE TAXES,  LT ON.
THAT M YOU HAVE TOAK
GR
RETURN TO MEETDL RATES.N INVTO T
ON MYAI TAX ETTING A LOWERETURNT
EFFECTSINGYOU'RE GOING TO SEERE
IN MORE TAX AVOIDANCE
ST
THE WEALTHY WANT TO  ONEANTO L.
SO THEY'REPEND
MONEY SEEKIN TO REDUCTAXES.
WHY NOT KEE TAXES I THIN T I BE.
W,USCT THAS IN FAIR THE PAY TN
THAT'S SORTFAL
RULE OF THE
BUIN H THE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD BE  WELL,E
NEEDS TTH
THE FED HASRA
ACCOMMODAND NOTHE MIDDLE CLA TT
AINS IN THE PEARBUYING GOINGENNS
WELL?
T'S NOTLE
SOHESE THINGS CAN BE EINOUESDITT
OKAY.
BUT AS WECU
LAST WEEK IS IW U. IS GOING RO S
IT'S MORE THAN PRICED IN.INK
OFES HAVETRUCTU D THEIUSROC.SI
TAKEN OUTIES OUR
OVERHE,  ESTATCOS.ONNU
ALLOW THEIR WORKFORCO WORK
THOSE  SAVINGS D THE
TTANSO BERUCTURAL CHANGES FOR T.
BUTHINK MORE
THAN FAIRLY ED
WE T I
WEOCHORTLLSO WE THINKS IHAVE A T